Remember, these
are homogeneous coordinates,
so here I wrote it instead of w but
with s's.
So it's full homogeneous
coordinate system,
which will go from
the homogeneous through a linear
operation to a scaled version
of the new x prime, y prime.
So, the full transformation
is referred to as a general projective
transformation, or a homography.
And a homography still
maps lines to lines,
because remember we talked about
prospective transforms always maintain
lines, and things that are inside of
each other stay inside of each other.
But this is what's typically sometimes
referred to as perspective transform.
So the idea is if I had a plane and
I was very close to you and
I tilted it this way.
And we'll do more of this later.
The edge that's near you will
seem longer than the edge that's
farther away from you.
And we'll prove later that
the transformation of a plane
can be represented this way.
Now of course,
because this is a homogeneous transform,
I can scale everything by constant and
it has no impact.
So I can make this last
degree of freedom be a 1, and
I'll get a slightly different w,
but it doesn't matter,
because I'm going to divide
everything through by w anyway.
So that 8 degrees of freedom,
that's the full,
it's referred to as the homography.